- My fear is that I'm gonna
like the way that I look
when professionally photographed.
That it's just a reminder
that I don't look that way.
- [Voiceover] What are you
most insecure about physically?
- What am I most insecure
about physically?
- Growing up, I thought I was too pudgy.
I didn't wanna take my
shirt off at the pool.
Then now that I'm an adult,
I think I'm, like, too thin and scrawny.
Intellectually I know that
I'm now any less of a man
because I'm not big and strong,
but it's hard sometimes to not look
at the people around
you and feel less than.
- What I think makes a man
attractive is athleticism.
I have a scar that goes
up my knee right here.
When I cut my knee open,
I was in the hospital
for like two and a half weeks,
and I was recovering for months.
I resent the fact that
it's made me weaker.
- I am proportioned like a skinny person
but I have no muscles,
instead I just have fat there.
I don't have big arms.
And I'd rather stay under the sleeves
that go all the way to my elbows.
I'm always in sleeves that
go all the way to my elbow
because then that covers
up every part of my body
where there's supposed
to be muscle definition.
- Yeah, if I have to open up here,
I don't really like the way
that I look most of the time.
I grew up in an environment
where I was beat up a lot
and I was made fun of,
and I was kind of told
everyday that I was ugly.
And then in the home life,
you know, being Korean,
I was also told that I could
always be improving how I look.
I don't talk about my feelings openly.
One wouldn't expect me to have
a lot of issues about my body
when I'm just riddled
with body insecurity.
- Normally, when we do shoots,
we always get really,
really beautiful models,
so when we do--
- [Keith] Okay.
- No, no, no, but I'm saying--
- [Keith] Alright.
- I'm recreating a John
Krasinski Men's Health magazine
photo where he looks fucking fine as hell.
I'm a comedian, right, I'm a funny guy.
And I've always thought growing up like,
funny guys get to look however they want,
and that's not it anymore.
Like Chris Pratt was like my body type,
and now he's an action star.
- Try and make those
shoulders a little tough,
though, look tough.
- How do you look tough
with your shoulders.
John Krasinski, same body type.
Now he's an action star.
You are supposed to have
this masculine-ness to you,
even if you're a clown.
- You have really, like,
feminine lips, I like that.
- I know I have very feminine lips.
- I never felt that attractive
until I met my wife.
So today, I'm recreating
a Cristiano Ronaldo ad.
And he looks freaking delicious.
- You got some big shoes to
fill, he's really good looking.
- Yes, I know.
(groans)
Muscle, everywhere.
Yes, I would absolutely wanna
look like Cristiano Ronaldo.
He's a Greek god.
Okay, here's my belly.
(grunts)
- Oh, okay.
- Now I just gotta stay
like this for an hour.
Being in good physical
shape is so attractive to me
because it's the opposite
of this horrible period
of time in my life when I was injured.
- We need people to believe that I'm sexy.
- We have to make you a Belieber.
- I'm recreating a Justin
Beiber photo today.
He's hot, Bieber's hot.
I assume we were born with
somewhat similar assets.
He was a small-ish guy, very skinny.
You know, to his credit,
he worked out a lot.
But, this photo got a lot of heat
because it was Photoshopped
pretty heavily.
I dunno who decided, but
they made Bieber more ripped
and they made his bulge bigger.
They gave him a bigger dick.
- [Yuichi] You went from a four to
like a seven and a half now.
- I was at a four?
Come on, man.
- Getting makeup professionally done
only confirms my greatest fear
that I have a big fat face.
So I'm recreating the
Magic Mike XXL poster.
Channing Tatum, front and center.
Triple threat. Really good looking,
can model, can act, can dance.
Films like Magic Mike series,
it is part of this enjoyment
of the perfect male physique.
Every guy wants abs, but
they're just so hard to get.
First you have to eat a certain
way, then you can't drink.
- [Yuichi] Do you drink beer?
- I drink everything.
I'm of the opinion that
these things are attainable
if you have the time and the money
and the team to constantly work out
and get that eight pack abs.
It's just, no one's that rich
or has that much time
except for celebrities
and actors and models.
It's not our job to look that good.
- Let's take some photos.
Masculine, masculine,
masculine, masculine.
- [Macey] I want you to walk into it.
So first one, so try to make
it look a little more natural.
- I don't think I've ever looked at myself
and then like, fuck yeah,
boy you are hot as fuck.
I feel like I'm not masculine enough.
Although I was told that I
looked good in the tank top
which is great cause I'm
terrified of wearing a tank top
because a tank top shows your arms off
and if you don't have
any arms to show off,
then you're just like, hey, look at me,
I'm out of shape.
Look at the gangly noodle man.
- Less sad, you look really sad.
Now you look scared.
- We're gonna have to,
maybe define the muscles
a little bit more,
make him look more rugged.
Good, good, that looks great.
- Yeah. Asian Channing Tatum.
I just know that there's so much about me
that is not up to par.
- [Macey] That was really close.
- This is tough.
Whether people think you
look good or you don't,
like, anyone can have
problems with how they look.
Hopefully we have at least
one that looks kind of like
the Channing Tatum photo.
- So when we send this to the re-toucher,
they're probably gonna
have to stitch his body
from different frames
and put them together.
- So he wasn't actually jumping?
- He's also a natural thruster.
- Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Right now, we're comparing
ourselves to this image
of someone who's like
beautifully sculpted.
That's not the most healthy thing to do.
- [Macey] Just like be Cristiano.
- Hey, I look pretty good.
Amazing what makeup and
lighting can do for you.
This is the way his body looks,
not because he's an underwear model,
but because he is a
professional sports player.
- [Macey] Kind of looks like
he's looking at something in
the distance. Like sexily.
- Like he's better than it?
- [Macey] Like he's better than it.
- Like he also wants it
It's hard to do all this but
also have a neutral face.
I might feel dismayed that I am not that,
but seeing the fantasy of
that might be really exciting.
I need positive reinforcement.
- You look great.
- Okay.
- That would be pretty
impossible for anyone, actually,
to be as perfect as Cristiano.
Props to Ned.
- I'll put the photo next to the place
where I'm doing push ups.
- [Macey] You look good, kid.
- [Ned] And that's before Photoshop.
- I feel like I'm definitely killing it
and have no self doubts about this moment.
I'll tell you growing
up, I never felt hot.
I felt like a nerd.
- [Voiceover] You look huggable.
I feel like Bieber's supposed
to look fuck-able, not huggable.
- [Macey] So try to look more fuck-able.
- Okay, that's it?
I'm sorry.
- [Macey] Why're you laughing?
- It's harder than I thought it would be.
Hopefully, I think that
it's alien and weird
and I'm like, nah, fuck
that, my body's beautiful,
I should love me, but I might prefer it.
I might prefer it.
How much work do you
think the Photoshop artist
is gonna have to do it to
make me look like that?
- If Bieber's wasn't enough,
they're definitely gonna have
to do something to yours.
- [Zach] Yeah.
- His bulge probably has
to be a little bigger.
(rock music)
- Now we have the Photoshopped results,
so we're gonna check them out.
- I have this fear of
seeing the final photo
and being crushed and knowing
that I can never achieve that ideal.
I think I look awful.
I hate this photo.
I look like a surprised baby.
I think a lot of guys use
humor as a coping mechanism.
If I don't laugh at this photo,
then the only other option
is to feel bad about it.
You haven't seen it?
Okay.
(laughs)
Oh my God.
I look like an action figure.
Everything that I'm insecure about
has been erased in this photo.
Looking at this photo now,
I feel like I should look like this.
Like should I not be okay with my body?
Should I be striving for this?
When I think of my attractiveness,
I think about my personality.
But as guys, you don't often
think of your body as sexual.
- I think a lot of men out there,
especially straight men, don't
necessarily confront that
as openly as LGBT men, but for me,
having to always constantly
deal with my relationship
with my body and navigate that,
this'll be really, really eye-opening.
Huh.
I was just struck with
a really great epiphany.
I've always wanted to look like this,
but seeing this now in front of me
makes me realize I'll always
have a problem with my body
cause I just thought that
my stomach still looks fat.
It really shows how me being
so hypercritical of myself
won't translate into
being more self-confident.
If you have a problem with how you look,
that's a way deeper issue than
just changing your outsides.
- I'm excited to see it.
I wanna see how I look, you know,
all swole and sexy, like Mr. Krasinski.
But I'm also afraid that maybe
it will make me feel worse about myself.
Let's see what a perfect
Keith would look like.
Oh, man, look at those arms,
those arms are huge.
Man, I look strong as fuck.
This is terrifying.
I don't like that at all.
No one wants to be friends with this guy.
This guy looks like a jerk.
This is Brad.
They put muscles on my shadow.
My shadow could beat me up.
While I lament that my body's not better,
I don't know if I really
wanna look like that.
Maybe I like my soft
body more than I thought.
- Having good muscles means that
you're also healthy and strong.
That is what I want to be as a man.
Healthy so that I can
provide for my family,
so that I can carry children up stairs.
Oh, damn.
I look like a god among men.
There's muscle there that I do not have.
Cristiano Ronaldo is so rare,
he's like 0.01% of the
population that looks like that.
If I wanted to look like
this and have my job
and, like, spend time with family,
there's just not enough hours in the day.
You're just seeking to attain something
that you can never get.
Earlier I said that the stronger you are,
the more healthy you are.
There's a lot of other aspects to health
that strength doesn't encompass.
If I did all the things I would need to do
to have this sort of body, I
don't think I would be healthy.
- I will always have
issues with how I look.
But maybe I can lessen those issues
by focusing on things that really matter.
People aren't gonna just remember you
because you have six pack abs.
They're gonna remember you
because you're a good person.
- I'm happy with my life.
Why is one photo making me think
that I'm not happy with my life?
I'm totally fine with who I am.
Improve yourself because you want to,
and because you enjoy it,
not because you're trying
to achieve an ideal
that someone has told you you should fit.
- Lots of people out there think that
like, if you're a guy, you should just,
you should work hard and be strong,
and if you're unhappy with
your body, you change it.
It's like, if you're
unhappy with your body,
maybe you should just
learn to love yourself
for more than just your body.
- I call these lines penis cleavage.
So my dick cleavage looks great.
- [Macey] One, two, three.
- Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.